avec les enfants c'est toujours pareil
ils sont très forts pour faire de la
patinette où s'abreuvaient dessin animé
mais quand il s'agit de les emmener au
musée ça traîne un peu des pieds je peux
vous en parler c'est pour ça qu'une
équipe d'animateurs s'emploie tout au
long de l'année et pendant les vacances
à offrir aux plus jeunes des sorties
ludiques dans les musées parisiens
exemple au musée de cluny consacré au
moyen-âge france aux vallées et raymond
chape l'art l'art et la vie au moyen-âge
au musée national de cluny
le programme est ambitieux pour des
enfants de 7 8 ans les plus grands un
groupe avec nos enfants on va vous
remettre une petite feuille
certains petits carnets de route et vous
allez suivre pas à pas toutes les
indications qui viennent marquer cette
fois ça devient plus intéressant
découvrir la vie des seniors retrouvé
les têtes les roi de juda tombé du
portail de notre-dame ou identifier des
sculptures des chapiteaux ici c'est un
travail d'investigation
à travers les énigmes ils vont découvrir
un petit peu la vie des épouses des
seigneurs au moyen âge en regardant les
tapisseries vont découvrir que des époux
c'est de la broderie quel final 1
qu'elles ne faisaient pas de vélo
qu'elle faisait pas de sport on va
découvrir le mobilier des églises qu'il
était peintre était décoré que les gens
au moyen-âge savait pas dire donc c'est
pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup de décoration
de cnet un jour le musée du moyen-âge le
lendemain le musée picasso pendant les
vacances et tous les mercredis les
enfants visitent ainsi la plupart des
musées parisiens
et quand on sait que saint martin
les musées qui de plus en plus propose
des ateliers pour prolonger des visites
un parcours de musée peut être adapté à
la fatigue d'un enfant à la curiosité
d'un enfant à la découverte d'un enfant
n'est plus bien sûr impossible d'oublier
les chevaliers leurs armures et leurs
grandes épées des garçons sont fascinés
les filles plus réaliste sur la vie au
moyen-âge
pourquoi c'était pas la belle vie c'est
bien la preuve que l'on peut apprendre
en s'amusant
l'air de rien les enfants ont fait en
quelques heures un bond en arrière de
milan